[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا نغمه دعبل عازفه قانون ومؤلف موسيقيه
من سوريا بدات تقريبا من عمر الاربع سنين
اعزف وجرب الات مختلفه بما انه البيت عنا
عائله موسيقيه
ولا مني اكتشفت القانون تقريبا بعمر 8
سنين حبيتو حبيت ان هو قالي كانت مش
منتشره كتير وكتير هيك بتتميز وبدات شارك
رسوله الاطفال
وكسرت الاطفال شارك بكتير مسابقات لما
بدات اعزف على القانون بالامارات ما كان
في ناس بيعصفوا هاي القالب هذا الشيء يعني
خلى علي مسؤوليه كتير كبيره وتحدي لحتى
اطلع الشيء الحلو خصوصا انه قالت القانون
معروفه عليها اله تقليديه وقديمه وكل
الناس يعني بتحسها بس للشغلات القديمه لا
انا حاولت اني اعمل منها شيء جديد فيرجن
يكون مودرن يوصل صوت القانون بطريقه كتير
حلوه يوصل الكلتشر العربيه لكل الناس مش
بس للدول العربيه ولكل انحاء العالم بس
بطريقه كتير
لما شفت القانون اول شيء بهديك الفتره ما
كانت ابدا من تشره وما كان حدا حتى
بيعرفها
وفيها كتير هيك تحدي ودائما بيحكوا ان هي
اصعب اله بس هالشي خلاني كثير اني اتحمس
اني اتعرف عليها اكثر وشوف شو فيها
امكانيات وحسيت صوتها وكثير فيها افكار
حلوه انه الواحد
يفرجها للناس وخصوصا بالامارات كبنت ما
كان في بنات بعزفوا على هذه الاله
فانشهرت انا كاول عازفه تعزف على هاي
الاله بالامارات وهذا الشيء خلاني انه
كتير اكتشف قصص يعني كانت الاله تنعزف
بطريقه كثير كلاسيكيه وتنحط على الاجر
وخلاص لا انا اشتغلت اكثر على الشو نفسه
اني اعزفه انا واقفه اهتم باطلالاتي
بالفساتين تكون مناسبه للدكريشن الموجود
كتير كنت بحب صمم كل شيء يعني
لحتى يطلع كله لوك كامل لما وصلت لمرحله
الجامعه حبيت اني ادرس شي مختلف وتضلل
الميوزك هي مجرد موهبه
فدرست الهندسه المعماريه بس لما بدات
بالحياه العمليه
الموهبه غلبت حسيتها هي الشي اللي بخليني
اعبر اكثر عن حالي
[موسيقى]
مؤخرا نزلت اغنيتي خلينا نعيش يلي عملتها
باسلوب ستايل يكون جديد على القانون لحتى
افرجي العالم انه القانون هو مو مجرد بس
قالت كلاسيكيه عربيه قديمه تراثيه بتنعزف
بس بالاسلوب التقليدي لا فينا نعزفها كمان
باسلوب عصري وفينا نضيف البيتس الاجنبي
وفينا كتير نعمل ميكسات ونوصل هذه
الاورينتل او النكهه العربيه بطريقه كتير
حلوه ناس بكل الاذواق وكمان الموضع عن
العصر هلا الجديد
[موسيقى]
فعزفتها لاول مره على الستيج
واختاروها لتكون على نافوره
اللي هي من اكبر نوافير الموجوده بالعالم
وهذا الشيء كتير شجعني اني دائما اعمل
الافكار الحلوه والجديده يلي بتوصل
القانون
لقلب المستمع يعني وعن جديد حصلت على
ميوزك واخذت لقب
بنصح اي شخص عنده موهبه وعنده هذا الشخص
بالموسيقى تحديدا لانه الموسيقى هي احساس
بالاخير يعني حتى لو الواحد درس او حتى لو
شو ما عمل الموهبه هي الاساس وكيف توصل
هاي الموهبه للناس فالواحد ما يوقف عند اي
اعاقه بطريقه بالعكس يضلوا مستمر ويتعلم
ويعطي هذا الشيء من قلبه حيوصل وهذا الشيء
يلي دائما نتبعو عنا
اللي هي الكميونيتي اللي انا عملتها اللي
هي بتشجع فيها المواهب وبشجع فيها اي
ميزوش الموجود حاليا بالامارات وبنعطي هاي
الجرعه من السعاده وتفاؤل للناس اللي
بتيجي بتحضرنا
[موسيقى]